hey welcome to my house do you like my
outfit this is such a nice house I look
like you're gonna wet my pants
don't wet your pants you don't even wear
pants how would you with them
not the face not the face all right help
me decorate my my house make it like you
look snatch snappy snappy look like ah
you don't even know what snappy looks hi
I know okay I know okay that's not
snappy I have this up here when you're
sleeping hey hey don't make me decorate
you your eyes you're a cupcake now [ __ ]
actually do that Oh Emma dinosaurs
you're all the dinosaurs
oh my thought what Alice I what are you
doing did I kitty what are you doing
Emma face nailed it let's go and play
some games here here's a dildo I should
we should we do community ones did you
do what did you say
don't Shh now I have to censor to this
video okay you got it hey you like my
bow tie
what did you put on me oh now you see it
just like a fetus going on yeah oh my
god I'm sitting here is it what
oh I'm first what what I don't wanna
make this is amazing okay now you aim
and then you hold X ah [ __ ] haha so this
is why we're playing a little big planet
to play mini golf and I can place it
whatever I want
okay no I can all right I'm sorry you
can hit each other's balls as well that
that's what she is
oh god no ILU what the value [ __ ]
this is why I made you play hahaha oh my
god Wow what's going on where are you
going I thought I seeked it shut up do
it do it do it oh oh my god that's awful
BAM
just one more than you - more than you
[ __ ] okay these guys like difficult I
can do this
heart of a warrior huh you can get a
hole-in-one with this if you'll ankle it
right you can do it dude I know how
physics work okay I believe in you
I don't need you patronizing me boom oh
oh that's not bad this is just good news
very good you can get a shot back if I
miss this yet
missa missa toe every city and let
amazing magic [ __ ] what why
[ __ ] I am the greatest you did you
just do that for the tension yeah oh I
did it
I am [ __ ] please hang on my face much
makes express shudders I thought that
was like you for a while oh oh oh oh oh
oh mister top of YouTube marry well I'll
show you because the more subscribers
you have the better ride Mini Putt
better a big plane so I need to live up
to this oh oh oh that was close but I
did yeah good games go game just a
silent clap yes yes thank you thank you
very much
actually you do you play golf I do not
but I've always wanted to be good at
yeah I'm okay so I feel like I should oh
boo dude oh dude what the hell
take it all back I tell you oh my god
that was amazing what did I do
damn it haha see I'm not gonna I'm never
gonna win now you can get this you can
yeah I know I know my good ego ah oh my
god okay this makes me feel good about
myself
yeah you bet I bet you feel really great
just playing with me
oh you're welcome oh yeah are you dying
- again 7:12 huh
all right this is the type of one where
I could could potentially yeah plus you
can knock my ball out as well so you
could read like mess me oh how are you
Oh what you spray water it squirts I
thought that was banned in the UK now
squirting link no Dave sexual activity
oh you're not allowed to squirt no the
Phantom porn for it really event loads a
porn in the UK recently how can they ban
squirting it's horrible
it's like the best no it's definite well
we can compensate from this so it's okay
it's gonna get flagged by the government
how dare they squid how how Felix oh
yeah I beat you yay unless he hit this
one oh my god there's so much lime
squirting yes oh it's like a blagging
squirting I love it stop it kid
squirting keep stopping what a little
[ __ ] God [ __ ] yeah yes we're gonna
finish this level we're not gonna finish
this level there you go oh hey oh hey
only two more cowbell oh I get to start
now is that how it works
okay whoever wins the hole starts nice
which you should've went the other way
yeah you're right it took me way too
long
alright let's time this boom ahh oh come
now
I played this with a random guy I
knocked him into the hole with this like
knocked him away from the hole he hit
the thing and then he went in oh my god
do is please knock me in oh ah ha
40 sorry Misun look what they get to you
and the aim goes all over the place that
you can't aim straight really go no that
was my chance to catch up you have
caught up way more than you should have
I'll come on what does that mean what is
that
does that mean it means you shook
there's so much lag
15:16 this is so close I can feel the
tension in my heart
jack team Jack there's no team Jack
hashtag comments on my video so
everyone's gonna vote for me
hashtag team Jack sucks hashtag I was
really mean I'm so sorry feel terrible
now oh oh no too hard oh that's kind of
gross I thought that was a shot I was
like shoot me man
shoot my ball shoot my ball my ball Jack
ah thanks why what are you doing daddy
coming towards my hole ah why I want
your whole Jack please it's all I ever
wanted what the [ __ ] was that I'm
tweeting out right now hashtag team Jack
for best golfer don't I'm tweeting at
right now hashtag hashtag go [ __ ]
yourself
haha well I'm busy hash tagging I'm
sorry oh really do you think I could do
it mister angles work for me yeah but
you got it you gotta be good
he actually said steak oh oh
best ever we have fun we are fought over
here no serious is having fun I never
have fun that's my moto oh you lost a
shot again yeah Blaine [ __ ] oh crap is
can this can this work here we go I can
we went through all the effort to play
LittleBigPlanet online you don't even
see it but oh oh whoa whoa whoa I was
full power and I I couldn't shoot when I
want to do so I had nothing but full
power to do we just play mini agent and
how do you do this I like how nobody
knows what's going on with them - don't
go back don't go back don't hit my ball
you hit my ball back you're going back
watch what no ever you know there we go
never ever ever going next
oh wait you're Wow how is it still your
turn how is he hard it took my turn away
huh
say hi oh I'm chilling in the corner
aiyee oh no no Oh mein serious that was
amazing with a capital Zed what how do
you spell okay uh charge it and a boom
in the ass oh my god it's so close it is
who will win the the bouquet of bouquets
or the dead frog fetus I'm a bouquet I
don't know why all right that's great no
don't stop stop oh I could sink that
[ __ ]
I could sing that it's like submarine oh
my god the so much like when I move the
thing it doesn't move in real time oh I
missed a shot because I was hashtagging
dammit I need to focus
can I go through this hole I'm at it I
don't think you have the angle unless
you can hit it off the side of this
thing here and go in but that's too
risky Jackie when I go through the hole
it's too crazy your head I do it ah what
happened with the lag what the hell they
charge like crazy yeah it's not bad it's
not bad wait wait wait writing something
I think I am what's happening anyone a
box ID you want it fax
I need dick [ __ ] outta me Jack are you
sure you wanna do that oh it happened
yank no no go back it's good that's good
that's good that's not a text me gloves
can knock you out from here Oh Nadine
cake
I play for ass
we got going here no no oh my god I
thought you would sink that's it
you're like a shot ahead now I think Wow
hashtag ass you don't need to be so
happy about it I mean I have feelings I
don't care oh it's time oh it's a tie
how many more is it wait that was it
that was it oh my god
oh my god we tied it tied oh well you
have it you still have a dead fetus
attached to me so I think I win that one
we didn't make the leaderboard really we
didn't even make the leaderboard no wow
that's harsh
sorry well okay this has been great